we are such um
we are we are so affected by what we saw
yesterday what we saw last week
and somebody goes away for a little bit
somebody takes a sabbatical
and we act like they never existed
so steph curry breaks his hand
last year plays two games in a beautiful
arena there in san francisco i feel like
they should be still in oakland but okay
all right bye great great arena
in san francisco and we act like steph
curry is
oh okay we got other we got luca
we got anthony davis steph curry okay
he's nice
nice nice little shooter steph curry
reminded everybody
last night he broke his hand but you
can't break his will
like 62 points 62 points in 36 minutes
at 36 okay in 36 minutes
that's the part that just blows my mind
he has 62 points
on 31 shots
yeah so so steph curry i'm not sure
about the warriors quite honestly i'm
not gonna lie to you
i don't know what the warriors are this
year i don't really think they're still
seriously
contenders about themselves what's that
they're still figuring out themselves so
you're not alone in that they don't know
what they are yeah
so but what he's able to do
and what he's been what he's been doing
in the league he always
he adds like this this is what blows my
mind about steph curry
like some guys come in and they do
something a little different
every year okay you know old school fans
that say hey
you know one year you know magic johnson
didn't have that baby hook
then he came back with the baby hook and
use it in the finals
or a guy does something with his left
hand and he never saw him do it with his
left hand before
or uh develop a three we never had a
three before
what steph curry does is continue to
extend the floor
every year like oh he can't shoot it
from there and then he shoots it from
there
24 25 28 30 feet so he's
unguardable in the sense you changed
basketball
he said he simply changed basketball
like i mean i mean the game is played
at every level um look at those made
because of steph curry
look at those mazes and what i loved
about last night
was not just the fact that he was
literally see what that shot chart does
not show you is that he was literally
throwing the ball up by the end of the
night
like i mean he was sprawled on the floor
he did
their heat checks and then there was
there was what wardell stephen curry the
second was doing last night see that's
that's his that's his alter ego there
you know what i mean like there's steph
curry
and then there's wardell wardell's the
grown man government name when rordell
comes out
you got a problem but the show went on
last night
because you referenced the jordan meme
earlier um did you see what he said
uh i did last night uh gary roll that
real quick let's let's have a laugh i
love it
cue the the the jordan meme right i take
all that personally
it's just a uh you know
opportunity to kind of assert my will on
the game early and try to
create some energy
i'm trying to figure out so all that so
michael when i said that when i when i
went on break
when black people go on break we break
like i was on break
like i was i was not paying attention to
any to much of anything where we were
gone right so i was i was literally i
had my head
buried in the sand i was under a rock
whatever whatever you want to call it
what was this death slander of which
they speak like
who was talking about steph curry in the
negative
to where he felt like he had to prove
something why would people what did i
miss
all you did no listen this you know how
it goes come on
you know how it goes this is this this
is what it is
you take a little bit a a shard of truth
and then you just kind of expand it so
if
it fits what you needed it says what you
needed to say
to motivate you to to the level that you
need to be motivated
so i'm sure
i and others talked about the warriors
not being contenders anymore i don't
think they're content i don't think
they're championship contenders
uh it here breaking news
that's what i don't think that's what
got his attention but that's part of it
that's part of it it's a little of that
it's a little of hey the warriors are
not
uh they're not as good anymore uh
they're missing klay thompson
steph curry is 32 maybe that's it you
know
32 uh he was out for a while
and then you just take a little bit of
that and you say oh they're saying i'm
not great anymore
they're saying i'm not the mvp and maybe
hearing some of the rankings
where was he ranked well i know
going into the season i had him seven or
eight or something like that in terms of
my projection for this season
that's not to say that he is based on
his body of work
the seventh or eighth best player
although you'd be surprised not you but
you'd be surprised how quickly you get
to seven or eight
but no i i think what it is michael the
universal phrase that i love is
yo man what has got to be all that i
think why why is it gonna be all that
like with steph curry i often ask myself
why is that to be all that like there's
this resentment
that for steph curry that's been out
there in certain circles
for a variety of reasons complicated
reasons
for years now like he went from this
baby-faced assassin that people thought
was cute
and his threes and he was cool and then
all of a sudden he became the bad guy
because we needed a bad guy
we needed a villain like i think lebron
got to a point where he was
more or less too teflon to be the bad
guy anymore
and so we needed somebody to juxtapose
with lebron
and when steph curry got the unanimous
mvp people tried to
pit him against lebron it's almost like
well you say
but hold on you said and i'm interested
now you got
you piqued me here piqued my interest
and you said
complicated reasons what are we talking
about here
we could be talking all day about it it
is the idea
that steph curry at the media favors
steph curry
that that steph curry gets a pass
okay okay is this uh no word where i
think
no fun we've long since gone there it's
been
that was going on like that's years ago
that's years ago i think
i think it's still beneath the surface
the idea that he has the look
that that mainstream media can embrace
and that therefore he was overrated when
he when he became the first unanimous
mvp
people took that as an excuse to hate on
him
and then when they went and got kevin
durant the warriors in general became
yeah a team people loved to hate in the
root against they became the big bad
warriors
versus those spunky upstart warriors
that they were that homegrown team that
they were
at the beginning they got durant now and
then he goes to the finals
and let's just say he underperforms in
the finals
that that can't be one thing he's got so
when he did that
and when we didn't roast him well if
lebron i mean you know how i go if
lebron would have done that y'all be
killing him how come steph gets a pass
how come
so and a lot of it is just rooted in a a
resentment not
not towards steph for who he is but i
believe
it's rooted in a resentment toward the
media
and how the media has accurate has
actually
handled these types of situations and
how the media has covered certain
athletes
so there is some um accuracy
if you will in the conversation but i do
think it's misguided in this place and
what it becomes
is you know steph is overrated or
you know well it's steph cuz is step
that good
without a super team the dude made 2 500
threes in 700 games
he's the goat shooter what michael
jordan was in midfield
i've ever seen what michael jordan was
in midair
what shaq was in the paint uh
or wrote before him what magic was brian
steph curry that's what steph curry is
beyond the ark he is a
singular performer he is as fun
and as entertaining a player as there
has ever been michael i'm too young to
have seen pistol pete maravich
but i imagine that's what it must have
been like watching pistol pete
watching a wizard watching somebody
literally toy with the game
i think they made a show about it steph
versus the game he broke the damn game
you know what i mean it's like it's it's
never been the same since
he was he he's been the greatest shooter
for years now
and all he does with performances like
last night is like you said on top
remind people of that fact
in dispute well you know what mike look
i i do think
when it comes to the nba finals if he
gets back to the nba finals
i'm sure he'd like to be the
nba finals mvp because it's the only
sport
i can say this check me on this check
any other check
check any other sport no other sport can
say this
we're the most outstanding player let's
just say it that way because they all
call it different things
in the sports we're the most outstanding
player
has never been a bum like the nba finals
mvp has never been but there's no bum
there's no ah he aight no no when you
win the finals mvp
that that is a sign know
oh well i'd say finals mvp the world i
got i'm sorry
the finals of ep nba finals i'm sorry i
got you okay
i'd say the worst the worst finals mvp
is probably his teammate
all-star but who was an all-star player
right
hey he he was an all-star with
philadelphia i don't have an
encyclopedic recollection of
mvps but it's hard yeah you're probably
right i can tell
i can tell all of them i i can tell you
all the the you know everything so
called
what's that you know every finals mvp on
the top of your head
hey i'll put it this way
i'm not putting you on the spot but she
was like i could tell you all you know i
like it
i like it i don't if you ask me if a guy
ever won it or not
i can tell you but i know like the the
so-called low end
we'd all be fortunate to be in in that
company
so you're talking about iguodala i'm
talking about like
guys who are not perennial all-nba
players
you got iguodala on that list chauncey
was cedric maxwell better than iguodala
is he better than anyone i don't know i
don't yeah i don't know i don't know i
don't know i don't know if i would say
chauncey is definitely better than
iguodala
i don't know but no i don't know
what i'm saying is for but for steph
to be that that's one thing he's missing
but that's how i'm in the
the larger point for him is this
i like that he takes all this stuff i
like that he takes a little bit
a kernel of truth and just blows it out
into something that it never was because
if it motivates you do it yeah even if
it
doesn't have to be true just do it
if it gets you going to get you focused
if you're trying to prove to people that
you're still
uh the best shooter in the league
and you still have to be you still have
to be feared
okay i don't mind it but i am surprised
though it was a detainer
on the other thing on the other thing i
don't know that's another show i don't
want to get derailed by it
i do remember and i was a little
disappointed in my man for doing this
i do remember a few years ago when
uh michael michael eric dyson dr dyson
wrote a piece about light-skinned mvps
and dark skinned and all this stuff like
you know cal steph curry is getting
getting credit because he's
light-skinned
and i was like how about lebron
hey come on lebron like
don't act like there's never been a
dark-skinned mvp in this league don't
act like there's having to be a
dark-skinned
mainstream player who gets a lot of
credit
in that lebron right it was michael
jordan i mean
yeah sure i mean magic johnson you can
go down the list
like no yes it's it's it's again it's a
it was colorism is a
conversation and a a legacy
that deserves attention um an
examination
productive examination i'm stressed
productive examination
but i always think i think the
conversation was misapplied
when it came to steph curry and i'm not
saying that's at the root of all the
criticism
it's also just our inherent like i said
inherent need
to you know even in our own minds to to
pick a side
you know uh i'm a lebron guy you know
you're you're a steph guy i'm a lebron
guy you're a kobe guy i'm a lebron guy
whatever it's just
and i just felt like at a certain point
it got to
you know no i don't i don't know that
many people were calling stuff overrated
but there was an insinuation i think
that's what he heard my understanding is
that that's what he heard
because i was catching up since last
night is that people were kind of
talking about
oh well you know what can steph do
without clay what could he do with our
super team as if he was some kind of
product
of the talent around him versus vice
versa
and the way it is now al the way it is
now mike
all it takes is
one or two people it all depends on what
you
who you allow access to you yeah i don't
even think it was that mainstream too
mike i don't even think it was like
right that's what i'm saying like
it yeah i think you might have all that
matters nba twitter
who will you give attention to yeah
because if you give attention
if you give attention to everybody
you'll hear everything
if if you're saying hey um i'm only
going to listen to
nba beat writers talk about me then
nobody's going to call you
overrated but if you open the field to
social media
you'll hear everything you hear that you
don't belong in the league you'll you'll
you'll hear that you're the greatest
player in the history of the league
you'll hear it all
so it all depends on what he's listening
to
my point is if that's if you're
listening to one person who calls you
overrated and that's the result
keep doing that keep listening to that
first
it's great for us keep putting on the
haters hey
much better back to watching fiasco we
saw last night
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you